hi Chinese check hailing hey Chad what's
up thanks buddy how are you it's Patrick
from the stand welcome to the show guys
yeah we're just talking I'm a bit
skeptical when it comes to the
paranormal Dan kind of says it eatable
yeah it's and it's it's hard to find
it's hard to find evidence that I find
credible it's difficult so that's what
the movies about though yeah and I just
told him I was I was in a I was in a
place that they said there's a lot of
couple strippers got murdered it was a
comedy club and I had my backpack and it
was my house yeah and a door slammed on
me that wouldn't like when I was going
to get my backpack in the open door grab
my backpack and it was only sort of a
windy day so where I want to slam that
hard in the middle of Hurricane sandy
but it definitely creep me the [ __ ] out
yeah yeah and I was going do you think
if a bunch of if Dan thinks that because
he heard that a bunch of strippers who
died at this club or been murdered at
this club at some mafia club or whatever
and and it became a comedy club and
that's where the door got slammed do you
think stripper ghosts would slam a door
like that I mean here's the thing like
out of all the years that I've done this
and I've been doing it for like 25 now
typically if I could guess and this is
all theories remember because this is a
field of questions not answers you know
right on its own two tragedies would I
would say would be the number one reason
that things happen meaning if something
really negative happened and it's been
completely like brushed aside yeah and
no one's you know acknowledged what it
is we've seen that be a case or be the
case in most hauntings where things
happen so if you think orrible happen to
this stripper yeah like moment writer
and no one is acknowledging it then
there's a good possibility that
something like that could happen so are
you saying that the TV show The Ghost
Whisperer with Jennifer Love Hewitt who
is close to being the truth you know
I've only watched that show a few times
yeah like some big titties
titties bringing people back yeah dead
yeah makes you go to gravity meet the
big titties are definitely the reason to
watch the show have you ever heard of
them have you ever heard an apparition
or anything talk yeah well we catch EVPs
all the time
what's that is embody my EVP is when I'm
like you're asking questions and there's
nothing in the room no way are you and
you'll get a response on recording but
you won't hear it yourself and there's
also what they call disembodied voices
which is when a voice will just come
ringing out of nowhere and I've
certainly experienced this over the
years what do they say the questions
you're asking you know what I mean it's
sometimes you get really intelligent
responses that are dead-on and sometimes
they don't make sense do you believe in
like the communicators like the little
little blonde kid on a that he's my
favorite I can't do that guy celebrity
medium I've been screwing on this
notepad and what I see is that your
sister died of cancer is that right yes
you know in the field of the paranormal
field I'm probably about the most
skeptical hunter I guess you could say
your investigator you'll find the
mediums don't really like me all that
well because I hey I don't get it
I'm not a psychic right so I don't
understand it and I was a part of a show
called paranormal State that included
psychic walkthroughs yeah I've seen how
they're made like they they basically
you know bring the psychics in and
they'll walk around for like three hours
guessing you know it's why we call these
guys guessers you know anything I said
sugar and they'll chop together the five
things they hit that actually makes
sense as opposed to than 95 things that
they miss okay from my fans you know I'm
trying to get something real and see
something real so when I see that that
doesn't say that that doesn't mean that
there's not psychic ability then there
aren't people that can hit it and could
nail things but I've never seen it not
if it was so vague right like like like
you know soft reading you never really
read things like we all naturally read
things yeah people in general the
subconscious is working all the time you
know so when you walk into a room I
could walk through a room and guess for
three hours there's gonna be five things
I
you know ya know in hats yes it's a key
thing that psychics always do they they
ask questions and then they then they
position it as proof like those say
things like who is John yeah I used to
learn someone go well John's my uncle
God he nailed it no he asked you right
and and the flesh is you who is John I
mean yeah the pressures on you to fill
in his gap what right what I want to see
him do is say you know your uncle John
yeah his last name is this and this
never happened so until I see that from
that kind of detail from the psychic
community psychical community or the
second medium community you know it's
just hard for me to say that I can
believe it I mean I used to watch
crossing over with John Edwards and it
always seemed like the biggest [ __ ]
why don't you watch it did inspire you
know I was stone on the couch at 3:30 in
the afternoon and it was on UPN or
whatever channel was on my business
partner went to his show just to check
it out yeah and and and he was actually
impressed by it really impressed me he
said live that that he pulls off some me
amazing stuff so I haven't you got to
see why like it's easy to be skeptical
when you're watching on a screen but
like so many of these guys are super
charismatic - right so like once you see
them and they're looking at you in the
eye and you kind of watch them do their
thing
you're hucksters you get swept up
they're touching you on your leg while
they're taking your wallet he's like oh
is this uh is this a new sweater whose
whose mark my dad brother yeah i watch
the i watch the cirno face movie how
much like it
you actually saw a 20 minutes longer
than the actual film that were showing
so you actually got more of the story
than most can I talk about the end of it
don't like give it all the way but if
you don't give away you know what I'm
talking about here and it's not gonna
blow this let me just tell you right now
he's playing in his deck what
I think cirno face is one thing is
another thing that's right absolutely
right okay but like I really the the
premise of the movie and you do it as
part of the I guess the tour this cirno
face goes to her is that so there's this
island in Australia and it's exactly
what you were talking about it's like a
very very haunted island well supposedly
haunted suppose they say haunted because
its history yes because there was a
prison on it and then they also found a
torture room you know it was buried that
they didn't talk about that was other
stuff was on top of it and and and
there's this ghost that is report I have
a question about the torture room you
mentioned how do they find the torture
room like what what made them dig down
there to find that there was the story
was there was some archaeologists that
were digging around there and they were
looking for Aboriginal artifacts and
they came across this okay that's how
this happens and so so the premise is
that this australian ghost hunter
paranormal investigator whatever found
this this ghost is apparition well back
up this actually what happened was the
australian government sanctioned this
paranormal investigation they had the
island they turned that they owned this
island that was a naval base and they
were looking for something to do with it
because it hadn't been used in swirled
war two so they turned it into a public
park and they put all these like amazing
tents and barbecue pits and all this
stuff and you can go there today there's
for free fairies it's a beautiful you
know you could stand and look at the
opera house the bridge but there's not a
soul on this island really there's a lot
on there well they don't cuz they're
scared of it bar after hundreds of
reports from from civilians and from
staff like that worked for the
government
yeah finally they were trying to figure
out what's going on so they reached out
to this gentleman craig who is the Craig
Powell who's the head of the West India
paranormal research team and they gave
him the keys of the castle essential
host Craig and he's he's got the only
known or one of the only known videos of
a full-bodied apparition yeah right like
you see how realistic is the video
extremely I mean I you know the video is
real
yeah let me start out by singing this
when I set out to make this movie I I
truthfully set out to debunk this man
are you a doubting Thomas
I am I'm a believer obviously because I
do this but you know I've just seen 99%
of most things can absolutely be proven
they really can so and that's the whole
movie is like figuring out if this guy's
lying or telling the truth and kind of
come on my journey right right and I I
went on your journey with you and I have
to tell you just based on you know you
say you can you read people and
conversations and stuff just as a person
I don't want to spoil whether or not the
ghost is a real ghost or not but as a
human being he seems like a liar of a
person like you seems constant suit and
the thing was like so many that that's
why every single thing with him I had to
like started with like right down to you
know where did you play football where
did you do that like I mean you'll see
in the movie I'm separating him from his
wife his friends like everybody to try
to figure out can I catch him in alive
when this whole thing started I looked
at him and said I'm gonna make one or
two movies because I want to tell this
story so there it's either gonna be this
amazing journey that you went on with
this incredible evidence or it's gonna
be a documentary about a dude that I'm
gonna expose to the world as the right
liar yeah
yes idea what was your first the first
moment where you said that he may be
full of bull sugar what happened well
the first time I've seen the footage and
when he told me it was a government
investigation you know I was like well
governments don't do this but then he
starts giving me all the paperwork and
it all adds up and then the government
contacts me and I'm waiting for them to
say to me hey you know we never did this
and they don't they say hey can you not
use our names in the email no [ __ ]
and I'm like whoa yeah well no I'm gonna
keep your names in because you're a
public servant but so you don't deny
this we have no comment you know like
they just didn't want to touch anything
the thing is I couldn't I couldn't catch
the guy lyin anywhere through slippery
when I finally took the footage to a
friend of mine Danny Patterson is like
one of the head CGI animators in
Hollywood he did the that he was like
the guy that brought transformers to
life okay did Iron Man Avengers Benjamin
Button I took the footage to
him and said like you know can you tell
me if this is CGI like like I'm not an
expert in this and his first response
which I loved he said well listen dude I
can't say this is a ghost cuz I don't
believe in ghosts
and I said well good just tell me is it
CGI or not and he came back and he's
like yeah no there's nothing about this
that says the CGI is that like yeah he's
kind of makes his own as well and you
could see the difference do these on
these island there are a lot of cases of
people being like touched or [ __ ] with
by these ghosts yeah touch not nothing
negative as far as like hurt or no one's
scratched that's good like Friendly
Ghost I'm more of a Casper guy I like a
good-natured ghost yeah but it's but
there's phenomenal things that happen
like the first story he told me and
again I had to see the footage of it
check it out for myself talk to people
as he said I had this personal
relationship with this ghost sir and
he's that we all do and he and I could
get him to show me his life like you're
welcome to say sir can we see your light
and like a lightning bolt this massive
light would go off in the road [ __ ] yes
and he's like I can do this when he was
a kid he would say that but it wouldn't
send a light it would be genitals excuse
me mark mom's boyfriend can I see your
life not only did he do it for his team
and you know having it film but he went
in grabbed skeptics literally like on
the mainland like who wants to come see
crazy guys I want afford him if possible
so he brought people from the government
and the government freaked what's the
island we're like wow cockatoo Iowa
hilarious name right sound that menacing
right no it doesn't wait till you
actually see it it's actually very scary
but what's really freaky about this I
said man someone there had to plug
something or whatever he was like oh no
knock yourself out like there's no power
to the building Hey look now when you
say the light would illuminate the room
would it be like just get brightest like
poof and the crazy thing is it's
so bright it's not casting shadows
meaning that like the light source would
be coming from everywhere it's just like
this giant flash that fills up
everything with white light then stops
this is Chad is there any footage of
this that's not in your film no I do
everything I'm talking about now is in
the film but is there any footage that
isn't this yeah yeah there's a bunch of
more footage of things that happened
they relive this guy up try it so we can
see somebody while talking to Japanese
see like his ghost no he doesn't put
anything on YouTube oh why because
that's like where footage goes to die
there's so much hoax footage on you know
here's the thing I'll be completely
transparent he never asked me for a bug
has still not asked me for a bug ever he
sat on the footage for over a new home
for a year before he told me about this
and that's a big point of mine the whole
time I'm like why I thought about this I
thought it's cuz ghosts don't like
YouTube comments - I don't know I'm
doing Don Pardo from SNL he's dead dead
people yeah I did you uh in them at the
end of the movie it says Cockatoo Island
is shut down yeah but then on the
website it says that you could still do
like it says they do glamping on
Cockatoo on what's glamping glamping is
like glamorous camping for rich folk
you're watching you do you're watching
the rough cut right so yeah right so
since that's happened what's weird is
they're saying that you can do like para
mole at or whatever right now yeah but
they don't take him anywhere if you
don't take me anywhere that they rat
it's a scam they just walk them around
the bottom of the island they don't take
them to any of the rooms none of the
buildings they tell them it's a
paranormal tour and then they don't go
to the place with the most paranormal
activity of course they walk around the
island telling the stories you know it's
funny when we went there to film because
I obviously I wanted to go in you know
in the place yeah and the second we hit
the the dock we were like four or five
of these guys that work on the island
just descended upon us and their thing
was like what are you filming for you
can't film there and we're like oh no
we're just tourists we're just tour
filming so they're driving around in
go-karts trying to find us and we had to
have like people be like the the lookout
to get an interview with Craig on the
ass like they did not want him on their
the in morning and why doesn't work why
this is what I think happened this is
just my gut and and Craig has his own
thoughts too which I think he's actually
pretty on when they put all this time
and money into this island and this took
them by surprise all this paranormal
stuff yeah I think they're sitting
around going wall you know not being
afraid of what it is I think they're
just kind of saying well we need to find
a way to flip this you know what I mean
so let's call like Craig who's like a
native son he's like from West Sydney
where this is at formal rug former rugby
guy it was a charismatic dude yeah and I
think they were looking for them to go
in and kind of make it fun and say yeah
we got an EVP we got a few footsteps
come on will like be your guide but then
he turns around and says hey come out
here and lightning bolts are going up
inside the building they're showing
footage of like you know this creature
this ghost like moving around and
looking at the camera and they were
freaked out I think they just went whoa
we don't know what's going on we don't
know why he's doing it stop it is it
footage of the ghost in this yes
chachi I have the the flash flash okay
and there's footage to the ghost too but
that's the feature so yeah yeah in the
movie yeah well that makes people who
doesn't want to see this audio only in
order to see it you have to go to the
sir no face lives you want the fast
forward a little bit to actually see the
and you can go to the tourists er no
face calm tonight in at the white eagle
theatre in Jersey City moaning tomorrow
at the white it says tonight Sam estate
and tomorrow NZ Kent Wednesday Count
Basie Theatre in Red Bank the arrow in
Philly and Ridgefield Playhouse in
Ridgefield Connecticut it's got you
tonight tomorrow Friday Saturday tonight
is Tuesday today the 15 the 15 oh you
know you know yeah we're in Jersey City
the white eagle theatres August 16th
August 17th read at the Count Basie in
Red Bank August 18th at the Trocadero
and August 19th at the Ridgefield player
Travis made a humiliating mistake
yeah you can get tickets at WWDC no
face.com you could watch all the
trailers all this stuff and end videos
from out this tour so you can see
people's responses and what they've
thought of it and and that's been the
funnest part of this whole tour is you
know the Q and a afterward it's been
awesome because everybody's like
skeptics are coming out believers are
out and and it's it's just such an
amazing case I don't you know do you
think the Warrens were full of [ __ ]
because I watched the conjuring movies
and then you know did all the Warrens
research but I think a lot of people did
you know and after the first one I was
like oh this is cool and like you know
read about the real Annabelle doll that
they have and all this stuff by Allah
and then the second movie came out and I
started reading about them the true case
the second based on and there were so
many holes yeah well I in that theory it
was like it made me be like um who's not
the movie makers that did that though
that might have been the movie makers no
no no there's there's articles and you
go back and you look at the articles
from the time and there's people
disproving the stuff that the Warrens
did
well the lots weren't the Lutz's shown
to be kind of [ __ ] - yeah well yes
and no I mean I know the raise my family
I have a documentary on my life story
called American ghost honor that's out
there right now and and Lorraine is in
this documentary her last case that she
investigators my family's case I've
known the rain for years the thing that
I will tell you about Lorraine is
Lorraine is very very old school very go
to Sunday School very religious like she
approaches everything with the religious
tone which not a lot of people dig you
know what she says at least I've asked
her about you know past cases and stuff
and she says that in all the cases that
she's done they have initially stopped
talking to media because she was saying
that in her belief that the reality of
anything that happens everybody is
trying to get a piece of it because
they're all right Gaucher's just like
the Luntz what happened with the Lutz's
everybody and their brother was banking
on that case and a motivo except the
Lutz's right my guess is the Lutz's kind
of realizes they relate to the party
yeah and then there are certain details
and interviews at the very end that's
started changing so make a little money
where they go oh we do
like if I had to guess I guess they're
kind of looking around going everybody
is rich off our stuff but us okay the
defeos didn't do well either no well
Ronnie's in I don't know look up Ronnie
DeFeo he's changed his story so many
times
who's the defeos I don't know the horror
he was the guy that killed his family
when yes they sparked the entire thing
and George Lutz and his wife are the
ones who moved into the house it sounded
like you guys was naming families you
grew up with good I like them good
barbecue fun he's had spouses though
he's been married Ronnie DeFeo so he's
still alive the guy who murdered his
family and amedy I'm not sure 71 I knew
was 74 years old no no he murdered them
in 74 okay
he's 65 now yeah it's one of those cases
that has you know I I did a documentary
called the first Amityville and what's
really strange you could also check this
out on a gh television calm my website
there it's about how Amityville believe
it or not it's a complete copycat case
way back in like 1912 in Iowa there's a
place called the Villisca ax Murder
House it's the same exact crime except
with an axe and not a rifle they don't
know how the person did it there was one
person there's a question of was it one
person or was it another did someone
help him they they got the they arrested
this guy George Jacqueline Kelly but
there's a he said a black figure came to
me and said suffer the children run to
me DeFeo said a black figure came to him
brought him to him like literally the
same case were they were like was DeFeo
aware of the case well that's what I
don't he like right for all we know he
read it or the Lutz's could have read
look we don't know but the the details
are identical so what about the family
after was there a family after saying
they saw ghosts they the family that
lived there after everything that's
lived there sense is not reported
I mean Amityville they have not there's
no Jodi to pig apparently that and then
they change the face of the house to
announce the the windows are gone the
Dutch windows that looked like the eyes
what's really it's back to this case
that was a copycat case the same thing
what's crazy about is the Villisca ax
when her house also had the Dutch
windows now do you think they they they
did actually just guess ticket tourists
Oh 100% yeah the people that are living
there just living their lives and this
is going on they know that what people
want what people were killed of that
house yes so crazy
well more than anything they know it's
the Amityville house if you riot you
should expect that's gonna happen you
know any people gonna be coming there
every single day it's you know to this
nation by a once I to be honest I never
I never have I've been through the
effort in the area and never stopped by
it but is going to something as intense
as this Australian island is something
like a medieval you like I don't give a
[ __ ] about that I kind of know what it
is I know where it comes from and
suppose case in general was the most
mind-boggling thing I've ever come
across I truthfully believe the footage
is authentic yeah the trail of people
that experienced this and and to not to
not be able to shake any of them and the
fact that again let's remember this
didn't start with Craig this started
with the government mm-hmm you know I
mean that's the whole thing that's the
weird thing
it did the start right we see that flash
yeah here you go all right there's no
you get hit play and hey guy here comes
they're in the dark right now
and you'll see this flashcar entire room
lit up you see them all sitting there
what's crazy is you see the interview
with riders a replay of it goes slow
motion oh no wow there's another one
again hold on there's another one where
it happens that the film that's coming
right up and you'll see that this guy
that that is responding to this right
he's Craig's travel agent he's not even
like a you know something he just bought
him out there to see it told him about
it check it out look at this see the
flash yeah are you in Sodor are you out
wait who's the guy with the flashlight
[Laughter]
this entire time has been Australians
freaking out of flashlights yeah I mean
that would uh yes it would freak me the
[ __ ] out oh yeah way especially theirs
they're one of my favorite parts of the
interviews when I'm talking to rob and
that's just one of his members on his
team that was out there and I say to him
like you he's talking about his
relationship and that he's seen these
lights and I say to him like you do
realize this sounds crazy as [ __ ]
everything you're saying he's like he
paused he's like I don't care and he
goes I went out to the island twelve
times twelve times I saw the light Wow
and you can see like the the you know I
mean like yeah but I wonder this soul
you know but is there like a ghost
greenroom where they're like
the lights for these [ __ ] morons like
we don't know that it's just me [ __ ]
taking a [ __ ] in the middle of a
middle-of-the-road
the waiting room in beetlejuice yeah
yeah look like what do you guys got
you're like I gotta go that Australian
[ __ ] former prison so you were you
were haunted when you were younger yeah
you know it's it's it's it's weird that
I would have never guessed in my adult
career that it would involve anything
with the paranoia I grew up in total
atheist I mean complete like my family I
never spoke of ghosts or God or my dad
was an airforce engineer I'm just a man
math and science right um when I was 12
years old my father unfortunately he was
out of the Air Force now and he was the
chief engineer at a concrete company and
he was in a terrible explosion that
burned 3/4 of his body and he was
supposed to die they the doctors took us
to say goodbye to him twice both times
he lived through and it's the first time
I ever heard my dad speak of anything
supernatural and the doctors were saying
this was a miraculous recovery and he
was saying well no it wasn't my mother
would stand and the burn warning and
burning it with him and she'd put her
hand on the top of his head it's only
place that he could be touched where he
wasn't burned she would just whisper to
him I'm here with you
stay with me I'm here with you stay with
me and he said that he could physically
feel himself being healed through her
touch and he found God at this time
again I didn't find God I became a
religious guy he became a religious guy
interesting and I did not I did not find
God or become a religious guy through
this story but it was working for him so
I wouldn't go and tell him no how old
are you in this house I was 12 so you're
12 and then he went heavy religion like
to do heavy or just kind of on religious
values religious for himself
push it off for anything but we had to
move to Iowa because once you heal from
you everly heal from a burn but it was
three forces bodies that start Jesus so
he couldn't be in heat but at the
southern taxes Wow he'd have a heat
stroke if you went outside for because
you can't sweat right you can't sweat so
we had to move to southwestern Iowa
which is where their families from and
because you know my dad loves children
and kids on stuff but the discard tissue
would scare them so he just didn't want
to be in a big city and all that type of
stuff
so they moved we bought and moved into
this town called Persia Iowa a town of
336 people yeah we bought a home that
the two previous families moved out of
because they said it was haunted and not
you know I'm really meaning just because
even my dad was religious that doesn't
necessarily mean he believes and goes to
God right and all this stuff that at the
time you know we didn't have a ton of
money so it seemed like a good deal that
it was the houses way cheap they're just
trying to dump it and get it off and in
that house is where everybody in my
family had experience and crazy
experiences that eventually my mother
Desha nari stuffed the film American
ghost hunter is me trying to determine
if my mother is just mentally
psychologically ill or if there is
something special what kind of stuff did
you experience and that see it's fine
these are the stories I hate to tell
because you can't you would never
believe it unless you were there but
it's your experience let me precursory
by saying yeah I get it you'd have to be
there to see it but look the first
experience I ever had that terrified me
and I was the last person everybody my
family experienced stuff until me and
I'm thinking my entire family is going
crazy at once what is going on I was
told my dad so many have a black spirit
that was or a black looking thing that
was at the end of his bed my mother is
saying she's being hit by things there
were spontaneous fires that started in
the house at more times so my just walk
in a room there's be a mini fire going
yeah yeah no I experienced that when I
was sitting downstairs with my entire
family and I hear it sounds like my
little sister's VHS is on upstairs yeah
and you know my dad's saying you know
Katie go turn your VHS you know your
chest up she's like I did know Mike
Katie I could hear it go turn it off you
know and she's you know adopt this she's
been you know three and four years old
it's time and I'm like Katie I could
hear it she's like I you know I turn
that off I run at the top of the stairs
I look back and her door to her room is
closed and under you can just see black
smoke just moving across the floor
what so I open it up and yeah her dolls
are on fire flames it could be and I
don't know what I heard but the thing
was there is no
this day there's no there was no source
of the fire well Katie was adopted do
you think that she might have done that
she might have lit the fire for
attention
I don't know how three years old she was
you three oh yeah well nor would we
leave for was something to light a fire
there's another barbecue lighter yeah
have fun go go by the chart play with it
Jim please play with matches in traffic
so where was your dad not but was his
face burned I know anything that wasn't
burned was his face all the rest of his
body was seen but it said they got to
you before he finally believed yeah so I
was my parents had gone grocery shopping
and I was left alone in the house which
is the first mistake well I didn't
believe again you have to think that
point in my life I've been I'm an
atheist even anything like that so I
walked around the house going okay if
there's something listening you do
whatever you want
like I want you're saying that oh yeah
no openly out loud out loud if there's
something here do whatever you want I
don't believe you no nothing happened
coughing this ghost face that night you
know I'm going to sleep and like
literally right as right as I'm you know
going to close my eyes I mean it sounds
like if somebody particular fist and you
just hit the wall as hard as you
possibly could to the point that it
rumbles the whole room I mean that's
what I hear and I sit straight up a bit
I'm like jesus [ __ ] christ like my
brother's room is adjacent to me so I
push his door open and I mean I'm out of
my room in two seconds my quota and and
I could not believe that he didn't hear
anything I was like there's no way you
couldn't have heard that so I'm already
playing devil's advocate to myself I'm
going you know what dude you were almost
falling asleep and you heard a loud
noise and you ran right and I'm thinking
this could have been a dream you're
freaked out in the 24/7 so laying down I
tell my brother I'm next to you bro I'm
not sleeping back in my room again just
in case I was right right and he's just
like okay whatever but I didn't hear
anything which made me feel better
actually I was like okay okay so
literally we're both like just kind of
talking about you know the things that
and dad seen he had an experience where
he went down to shoot a pool ball and
you know the pool balls some of them
have a little black circle right on the
wall and the pool ball move didn't roll
slid when he went to hit it and we were
talking about that and right as we we
fall right as same kind of thing Ryan's
were falling asleep I think he might
actually been asleep I was still awake
right as my eyes start to close boom
back of the wall again I see him sit up
and he looks at me and I'm like no you
heard that mm-hmm
and we're like both sitting there and
boom boom boom it just starts happening
on alternating walls no so this was my
like first experience were the first
thing that happened to me where I was
just like what yeah I mean and it
continued on that night I mean that was
the first night my mother had possession
area shoes where my dad woke up to her
speaking weird and being her hair pulled
and my things that weren't there she
scratched and when at what point are you
like let's just [ __ ] yeah I do not know
your mother how do you not know was they
try to learn to sweat dad we're going
back to Texas what you thought it might
be at first well of course I mean I mean
I'm even to this day even having seen
the things I've seen again I still I'm
still a believer in science you know
like 99.99% of the time there's an
explanation
yeah but the but the one by the way is
this the ghost right here but no one
else do you see this but our show yes
we're not showing that to anywhere can
we see that just watching peace out yeah
this is the video the full-body
apparition that nobody has obviously
yeah yeah there it is and then just
chilling what you'll see they'll bring
it back up and it will slow it down for
you
yeah oh he likes got old-timey face
though is that a shadow how tall is he I
don't want to give it a good question
damn good question yeah that's [ __ ]
creepy what's really cuz he looks like
he lives there and he's like hey you're
still here
you want anything water no you are my
friend eating trick you good didn't you
he's like the end of Ferris Bueller like
you're still here anymore like bathrobe
yeah the one thing about the footage to
me that hit me right away is in the 25
years there's a this there's twice but
when these things manifest they get
physical I've seen that at my house
that's kind of point I was getting in
the 25 years that I've done this I've I
believe I have seen seen it goes twice
ok and two things about it both times
blew my mind one being that there
appears to be some sort of mass to a
degree mm-hmm
and secondly they just move independent
of like of like our physics and the way
we move there's just a fluidity to how
they move and the way this kind of moves
in and moves out especially its army
like it doesn't look like so we see this
full-bodied apparition as it's called
peek out a doorway and then go back in
so it disappears but it doesn't when it
moves you're right it doesn't move like
people use maps and look like I'm
stepping and then stepping it looks like
it's flowing I disagree because watching
that it kind of looks like you just pop
around a corner but yeah the other here
and there like it looks like if you
thought someone was in the other room
and they go hey no face can you see that
camera crews still there yeah I mean
it's human issue no Danny the animator
that's one of the things that they do as
animators as they study the physics of
the human body yeah because when they
create stuff they got to get it right
right and and that's when things that he
said to me - he said humans don't don't
just move that perfectly you know what I
mean yeah we see it again we just we
just by nature we
turkey jerky yeah yeah because it does
but I'm saying this there does have like
a little bit of a human movement tinge
to it or pleasure show her my no face
yeah he's like this he's like I mean it
is [ __ ] terrifying I've seen a ghost
now it's just the music not not right
after this it comes see there is kind of
like a fairy like look at the shoulder
there's kind of like it's like yeah yeah
you know what I mean like it dodges and
moves back super yeah yeah yeah like
humans by nature just a little more
herky-jerky
yeah you know what I mean it's crazy
stuff man it's crazy crazy footage yeah
what do you think Jim it's hard to say
I'm so skeptical the whole thing was
funny I hope you get a chance to watch
to watch i watch the whole thing footage
and like showing it to like the cgi
animators showing it to this guy what
makes anything real or fake is context
right right and and that's one thing
that Craig did that was smart when he
said cuz I said him why he ever thrown
in YouTube and he said on YouTube
there's no context anything it's just
another piece of footage that's on
YouTube if it's just by itself on
YouTube yeah everything is fake on
YouTube right like that's what so it's
really smart for him to do that to keep
it off you know but that was my whole
time with him I was like did you set a
trap for me you see that in the
beginning of home rhyme I'm asking him
to his face you know I mean I'm just
like did you do this you you knew I was
coming you came to my show you know what
I mean you met me here mm-hmm you know
but again I knew him for a year and he
didn't tell me about it
a year after I knew and then he didn't
tell you about this island or anything
about it until after a year after he
knew you you gotta see this yeah well it
happened some of my fans over
they're said we want to go ghost hunting
with you you brought your you know this
film about red sky over but we want to
go son
I don't know where to go some of the
connections he had the west Sydney
paranormal research team that's his team
so I called him and said do you have a
connection and we can go to I'd like to
do an event for some fans and he said
yeah actually I have access to this
Island right now you know you can do the
event out there and at that time I
didn't really looking at the island that
much you know I was like oh okay cool
he's got a cool place
I'm just before I went over there I was
just like what what is this where am I
going you know what I mean
so it's it's the craziest experience I
have ever been a part of I truly
believed in the beginning that at
between him and then eight members of
his team and all the people that were
involved and the government I figured I
would catch somebody tripping up here
yeah yeah somebody nobody did nobody man
not even close and you see in the film
there's many times where you talk about
where I think I got him maybe he lied
about that oh I think maybe I have him
here and I mean I'm going all the way
with it like I'm sitting his wife down
looking her straight in the eye and
going you have every reason to Oakes
this right like don't you know I mean
like we're going after it and the bottom
line man as I couldn't find announces
well were you guys in the room when that
thing happened or where was this I
wasn't this was during their that so
when this happened it's like four hours
and thirty some minutes after the island
the guards had locked the building and
shut it and they just left a can which
is very common and when you go something
you just leave cameras and rooms your
biggest spot plot it leave it on and and
the hope is that in a perfect world
something like this happen who saw this
footage for the first time well Craig
was the one who found it but he was not
on the island when this happened
his wife was and three other team
members yeah and two guards which but
like in the morning they come in in the
morning and like rewatch the tape and be
like oh no in fact it was a night that
they reported that nothing really
happened they just they didn't see this
in the morning they just showed back up
in the morning grab their camera they
left it running overnight got the guards
to unlock it open it back up left went
home dump it the footage off to Craig's
he's got the deck
and then a couple days later a couple
nights later you know he came across
that say you know so have you ever been
in a hotel sure and you're like this is
[Laughter]
how he leaned on the floor it's gone the
next day have you ever been in a hotel
that that you feels haunted
oh sure and they don't tell you yeah
well yeah it depends some hotels
obviously realize there's a financial
benefit to saying it's haunted yeah
people don't like the Stanley Hotel yeah
Bart Colorado right they had my mom
worked there called the Stanley in Estes
Park Colorado is that where the shiney
was shot the old days where overlook
hotels were shot but Stephen King had
his experience staying in that Estes
Park spam yeah is the Stanley a nice
hotel yeah Stanley Gary my mom worked
there in college because my mom went to
college in Colorado and in Estes Park
she worked at she worked at the Stanley
and she said like it was haunted like
really like she said she'd go into a
like a banquet room and and they would
they would have the tables set up
everything after like a dinner service
they would like clean the tables and
have them all set and then the morning
when she'd come in the tables would be
stacked on each other like moved into
weird places in the room walking doors
like give a hug a guy getting out of the
tub
that was my character was based on my
mom I want I'd like to stay there and it
still is still active hotel yeah it's
it's all I have you know all of our you
know rolling some footage for you guys
to see from the Stanley amazing piece of
evidence I captured their mind my mom
worked there in uh but I think right
before the shining came out or before
the shining and she said like the staff
was pretty much just like as the ghosts
there's like a lady that a whale at one
point it truly is like but they're like
yeah they're like it's normal they're
just like nano is just like normal
what's the footage that you're gonna
send to Roland what is it it's myself my
wife and a friend of mine and we're in
the employee break room and you hear
these four boot steps walk up to us and
it happens at a time where I literally
accidentally and drop the camera and you
could see my feed my wife speed and the
guys that
we're all wearing like rubber sneakers
so you know it's not let's go and click
click click in front of us to the left
there's a little breakfast table in a
chair you could hear it slide on some
urn and my wife who is not a ghost
hunter it's a schoolteacher I'm just
like forcing her out there with me you
know what I mean you hear her scream
bloody murder and right in the middle of
the room this black shadow just stands
up like I said there's some kind of mass
to him yet like envelops over this
string that's saying you can see it in
and just with the same fluidity that you
see here
fires out the room and and I'll see you
guys as you could see it pretty soon I
won't sit in this room if you're gonna
yell at me the ghost the seat what year
did you film this in the Stan Lee this
have been back I want to say 2006 ok and
what's so funny about ghosts ending with
people that are not good I hate it I
hate taking her out cuz it's a lot of
it's like you're sitting there it's like
what's that it goes so I'm gonna happen
to him I don't know babe so this is what
you do with your time yeah is it yes
have a good 30 minutes to get there by
the way it's gorgeous Drive yeah [ __ ]
gorgeous a place to stay for a couple
days oh I don't know I've never stayed
there it is it is it's a beautiful place
they've got an awesome restaurant there
great view like no matter what it's just
the most beautiful
I'll have the ghost cutlets please it's
really really funny that's great that's
really something spectacular yeah I'm
always fascinated by that because I
think more than them I probably I
believe in ghosts well you know one of
the reasons that I love doing tours like
this is the US Gallup the US Gallup poll
and Monash University which oddly enough
is an Australian University they both
conducted I want to say it was in the
early 2000s 2003 and then I think 2006 I
might be wrong on this you can google it
out there in radio man but they both did
two separate surveys to determine
worldwide belief in the paranormal and
both of them independent of each other
basically figured out that it was
somewhere between 70 to 76 percent of
the population actually believes in the
paranormal yeah and what'd I just say
about that I said Wow so if there's like
you know six million people in the world
and say seventy percent believe in them
I mean if you just take claims
that people have claims I saw something
I know it this moved I saw it we're
talking about hundreds of millions of
claims a year that go on with the
paranormal only it takes one for it to
be real one to be authentic for it to be
real right what I mean so does right
because there's certainly a degree of
hoaxers there's certainly a degree of
crazy [ __ ] honest mistake
there's yep there's a degree of honest
mistakes and but there's also that like
that that shaving of 1% of things that
just don't make sense right you know
what I mean and it's just in the world's
filled with those what do you think of
of all the movies especially lately I
feel like the paranormal as a subject
matter in horror movies has become like
the new thing with the the conjuring
universe cuz it's spawned off like what
four or five that was a very friendly
the conjuring yeah you see the conjuring
too
you see Annabelle I see I didn't like
the skinny thing in the conjuring to I'm
like um right but the original conjuring
fright but that's the thing about the
like those movies is that they started
actually showing the the demon or the
thing that was and so you you're taking
a risk when you do that because back in
the day it used to be like you wouldn't
actually see the monster I heard a ghost
I was a kid I would stolen where's your
word you hear what you hear in my room
oh yeah I said where you sleep I'll talk
about we start with Tommy kisses we've
all been sharing what happened with the
ghost in the room just said one thing
what did it say I like dicks
Sam was a prepetition soundbite of me
out of context it was a total
interruption but what do you think of
well of the night you Oh Jim you well
you know what's weird like you know as
someone who is obviously heavily
involved in the paranormal field before
all the TV shows I mean I was a decade
in before that all started happening I
wasn't surprised that it became a
popular thing once the web really
started taking over because all it took
is for people to have the ability to
share anonymous yeah and then I see why
but why do you think people are sharing
why do you think the anonymous like that
was it because
want to sound crazy he's an example yeah
the morning after I had my first
experience and I remember sitting there
just staring at my breakfast and we know
my best friend like yells my name he's
like Chad and I'm like why he's like
what are you doing and I remember just
sitting there thinking okay this
earth-shattering event just happened
that just ripped apart my belief
structure and I can't tell a person
because I will be a liar right I will be
crazy yeah I will be seeking attention
but yet this this event happened this
happened in my life it's just like when
I you know always say to people at
events when they show up it's like if
you came here for me to convince you
that ghosts exist I can't do that
because you have to experience it to be
convinced but what I can do is tell you
I believe and show you why well check it
also says that you debunk and it says
you developed a reputation as a leading
deep bunker and you discovered rational
explanations to many of the world's most
famous paranormal which which one that
you that was a famous one that you kind
of thought was a rational explanation to
me one of the most famous ones was I
knew it was something that was publicly
thrown out there by networks and
everybody else in Louisville Kentucky
there's the Waverly Hills Sanatorium and
it is this five-story 180,000 square
foot abandoned tuberculosis hospital and
these the legends that were on TV and
all this time said a couple things they
said that 60,000 people died like in
this building what a shitty Hospital
[ __ ] I hate to go there well we knew we
knew when strata myosin we knew in
streptomycin was invented and we knew
when they you know that's the cure for
and we also knew you know when the
building switched over it became like
this geriatrics home and we also can
could through our own research we found
a statewide number of people who were
basically afflicted with tuberculosis
and what we figured out is that if it
was 60,000 people literally one person
would have to be dying every like 1.2
seconds like like this is [ __ ] you
know what I mean
at the same time in
and room on 4 or 5 there was a story and
a legend of this nurse ghost supposedly
that became pregnant by a doctor there
and he killed her and buried her body
and that she later hung herself in room
503 well we were able to you know her
name right now slips my mind um this was
you know back in 2006 that we did this
but we were able to determine that there
was no one by her name ever hired there
and cording to the logs on the records
there's certainly nowhere there's
nowhere on the property anybody knows of
anybody being buried as far as her but
more importantly what they're calling
room 503 if you look at the original
schematics room 503 was a hallway okay
wasn't it room so there's no ways
younger selves your hallway so things
like this that we do when we go into
places because you want to determine
what is really if a legends fake I don't
want to chase a fake legend right what
become is what becomes it becomes legend
that turned out to be to be nonsense
that does hurt the cause right the ones
that are fake I totally agree and just
thing is it's like you have to be
skeptical in order to I think a to be
taken seriously but be to find out
what's real you know I mean you don't
want to waste your time running after
something that's just simply made up in
the movie and said that you were not
doing this anymore
that you are not doing a paranormal
investigation yeah I've done it for a
long time and then the primary reasons I
truly believe this footage to be
authentic and that was my goal my goal
throughout my career I wanted to capture
that evidence that is what pushed me and
drove me to do it so do you feel like
this was it like yeah I think he's done
it you know what I mean but but at the
same time I'm extremely honored that you
know fate and destiny put me in a place
where I could tell the story
yeah and play a role in and getting out
there you know I mean do you think other
ghosts are pissed at no face for showing
footage though I do they caught you on
tape looking to see if it was there I
didn't really let the camera know all
right he's doing his [ __ ] lightning
trick why isn't he in trouble
because because he doesn't show up
physically you're not allowed to put a
shadow yeah that [ __ ] moving is that
crazy yeah it screams [ __ ]